on peut dire aussi que ces quartiers
sont parmi les plus pauvres de france je
parle là du département de la seine
saint denis c'est le département le plus
pauvre de france
or il atteint un record de surmortalité
juste derrière le haut rhin depuis le
début de l'épidémie
comment quand il expliqué si ce n'est
que ce sont des lieux où les habitants
sont entassés plus entassés qu'ailleurs
qui a trois formats de médecins que qu'à
paris par exemple qui a moins de grandes
surfaces aussi qu'ailleurs donc quand on
fait ses courses sont des plus proches
les gens les uns des autres que les gens
ils traiter les travail assez peu vous
l'avais dit il ya à paris il ya dans ces
quartiers beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnel soignant à savoir des
infirmières des aides soignants mais
aussi des caissières des caissiers des
livreurs des éboueurs tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en première ligne habitent
dans ces quartiers dits sensibles
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai alors on a
beaucoup et c'est d'ailleurs il faut
penser parce que les premières victimes
des désordres
enfin quand on quand on a comme ça s'est
passé à meudon par exemple une dizaine
de voitures qui sont brûlés il faut
peut-être s'interroger pour savoir qui
sont les victimes dès qu'elles sont bien
assurés pour le risque d'incendié de
leur véhicule s'est pas du tout sûr
dedans vous avez des gens qui vont
gagner qui a un peu d'argent qui
travaille au service du de la population
aujourd'hui en tout cas parce que les
gens qui travaillent aujourd'hui c'est
au service de la population et qui
méritait pas qu'on leur rôle en plus
leur voiture
donc là on est les premières victimes de
tout ça c'est des habitants du quartier
d'abord mot d'ailleurs c'est en visitant
ses quartiers en rencontrant beaucoup de
ces personnes et en gardant beaucoup de
contacts avec elle que aujourd'hui je
prends la défense des habitants des
quartiers mais je peins pas la défense
des habitants des quartiers contre les
habitants des beaux quartiers
je prend la défense des habitants des
quartiers contre ceux qui pourrissent la
vie des habitants des points
[Musique]